[Music]  every year we dump more than 8 million  tons of plastic trash into the world's  oceans small harbours like this one are  good places to test a new cleanup device  on the Spanish island of Majorca  Andrew Turton and Peter Czerwinski are  trying out there floating rubbish  collector the seed bin here's how it  works an external pump creates a vacuum  that sucks in water along with the  floating trash the filter bag inside the  bin even removes oil and detergents from  the water  the designers say it doesn't harm fish  because only objects at the surface are  pulled into the bin at present the pump  is still being powered by gasoline  but in the future Andrew and Peter plan  to use renewable energy sources like  wind and solar to run their ocean  cleanup device do you like that  [Music]